donc bienvenue dans le canton d'enim
nous sommes ici au musée de la régance à
enim cheflieu du canton de NIM nebisac
Nim commune de 7500 habitants avec
beaucoup de d'attractions de
développement économique mais ce musée
du du du mineur musée de la Régence avec
cette fameuse météorite ici présentée
également une des belles collection sur
le néolithique notre passé très ancien
et ainsi que du passé plus récent plus
contemporain avec le le musée du mineur
donc qui rappelle l'histoire des des
mineurs de mine de
potasse somm à inscem devant la zone
d'activité d'intérêt
départemental une entreprise est en
train d'investir l'entreprise bumendorf
hein qui construit une nouvelle usine
premier bâtiment est en cours de
d'achèvement la politique de
développement économique dans notre
canton est primordiale ici à N Sissa
mais dans dans toute la communauté de
commune du centre orin et dans la
communauté de commune du pays de
briisac pour pouvoir partager de la
richesse il faut d'abord pouvoir la
produire c'est ce que nous faisons pour
faire baisser le taux de chômage mais
aussi pour apporter des subsides en
terme de d'activité de d'investissement
public